on va retrouver à bamako sega diarra lé
politologue et fondateur du journal en
ligne
mali actu bonsoir à vous merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
pourquoi l'agent tatel reporté
aujourd'hui une réunion avec les
organisations politiques et civiles
merci donc aux comme vous le dites
aujourd'hui il y avait une organisation
qui était prévu afin de discuter donc
des contours de la transition et de la
suite à donner à la cedeao par la junte
malheureusement dans la forme de leur
convocation dont la junte n'a pas pris
le soin de mentionner le nom du n 5 et
afp qui reste qu'à 20 la plus grande
organisation politique qui a été fer de
lance du départ du président ibrahim
boubacar keïta et c'est à la suite de
cela que cette organisation a diffusé un
communiqué hier soir en disant qu'elle
ne participerait pas à la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui
donc c'est face à ceux des chèques et
face au fait que les principaux acteurs
donc de la chute du président kita ne
serait pas présent que l'agent traduire
et portait donc la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui et nous appelons au même
moment qu'elle prévoit et dell demain à
partir de 15h d'accord donc une nouvelle
réunion demain avec lm 5
quel est l'état des relations justement
entre cette organisation de la issus de
la société civile et la junte parce
qu'on sait que l'imam dicko par exemple
un qui a mené toute la contestation
contre le président déchu ibrahim
boubacar keïta et bien ils
s'impatientent et semble s'impatienter
parce qu'il a déclaré que la jante
n'avait pas carte blanche
absolument ce qu'il faut noter c'est que
aujourd'hui nous constatons une relation
de méfiance donc une relation de grande
méfiance parce que au lendemain de la
démission du président le keita la junte
a appelé et a reçu toutes les
composantes politiques de la société
malienne et des acteurs de la société
civile mais sans le m5 est resté là
junte n'a jamais voulu inviter le m5 lfp
à discuter de quoi que ce soit c'est
face à cette situation que l'eau ce
groupement donc qui est composé des
membres de la société civile et de
l'ensemble des partis d'opposition ainsi
que
quelques groupes religieux ont décidé
d'aller rendre une visite de courtoisie
à la junte a son siège et malgré cette
visite de courtoisie je pense que les
lignes n'ont pas bougé parce que le
lendemain la junte a publié donc un acte
fondamental sans en parler à la société
civile ni avec le m5 afp et encore moins
la classe politique
donc aujourd'hui on nous pensons nous
constatons quand même qu'il ya un
sentiment de méfiance et que nous nous
acheminons donc vers un bras de fer se
brade ferrique qui va donc déterminer la
suite des relations entre la junte et le
35e
surtout que l'agente a confirmé
considérer son leader comme chef de
l'état comment est-ce qu'il faut
interpréter cette information alors
aujourd'hui
l'agente essaye de faire de la politique
au vrai sens du terme donc en essayant
d'exclure plus ou moins les force la
mieux organisée du pays la force
politique la mieux organisée
quel est ce qu'un le m51 et tout en
essayant de recul tu es au sein de ce
mouvement là mais sauf que aujourd'hui
elle se retrouve face à un dilemme parce
que la cedeao ne voudra pas d'un
militaire à la tête de la transition
mais mieux la cdo demande à ce que les
militaires ne soient pas au dessus du
président civil de la transition ce qui
donne quand même un pouvoir
supplémentaire donc m5 rfp qui reste
comme je les dis tantôt la force
politique la mieux organisée du pays en
ce moment la cedeao qui a mené plusieurs
médiations qui ont échoué mais
aujourd'hui elle tente de se rattraper
elle exige donc une transition de douze
mois c'est ce que l'on comprend puisque
elle souhaite le transfert immédiat des
du pouvoir aux civils et des élections
dans 12 mois s'esquissent était même
passée on s'en souvient avant en 2013 je
crois vous allez nous le dira et
justement elle demande aussi que ce soit
une personnalité civile qui conduisent
cette transition ça peut être qui alors
aujourd'hui il est très dangereux même
très pernicieux de ma part de me
prononcer ce qui peut diriger cette
transition là mais ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que la démarche de la cedeao est
plus ou moins cohérente dans la mesure
où elle se met dans une dynamique de
démission du président habré
boubacar keita et non d'un putsch
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui peut expliquer
l'assouplissement des sanctions qui sont
en vigueur
mais aujourd'hui nous constatons que la
cedeao souhaiterait qu'un cadre des
missions donc en cas de vacance de
pouvoir
ce n'est nullement pas à l'agente de
constater cette vacance de pouvoir
mais plutôt la cour constitutionnelle et
cette cour constitutionnelle donc doit
réunir l'ensemble des forces politiques
pour pouvoir décider des suites donc de
cette transition
aujourd'hui nous pensons bien que la
forme y est là seulement il va falloir
maintenant trouver un nombre de
consensus mais le plus important ce ne
serait pas temps qui va être ce témoin
providentiel si je peux dire ainsi mais
ce serait plutôt de dégager des critères
donc des critères qui permettront de
rassurer et toute la communauté
internationale et les maliens mais aussi
qu'ils donneront une certaine légitimité
à cette personne-là qui aura la charge
de diriger cette transition est une
transition d'une durée de 12 mois auquel
quelle chance pour cette ce délai alors
ce délai me paraît assez court mais
aussi je pense que au regard des
attentes des maliens de ce qu'il pense
de cette transition
parce que ce qu'il faut noter c'est que
peut-être la cedeao n'a pas pris en
compte cet aspect là c'est que cette
transition n'est pas une tradition de
type classique on ne quitte pas un
régime dictatorial pour passer à une
démocratie mais le mali était déjà une
démocratie donc il va falloir consolider
cette démocratie là est passé parce
qu'il ya des institutions qui n'ont pas
correctement fonctionné et ces
institutions là aujourd'hui c'est
notamment la classe politique le mode de
recrutement du personnel politique mais
aussi la façon dont les institutions
interagissent entre elles
donc aujourd'hui le chant est très vaste
se précipiter pour aller aux élections à
ne fera que reporter le problème de fond
qui consiste quand même en un problème
de la fondation du mali merci à vous
sega diarra je rappelle que vous êtes à
politologue fondateur du journal en
ligne
mali actu sion